MALE SPEAKER: This is
the first of our
two datastore sessions.
You've already learned about the
App Engine, so we're now
discussing this important
peripheral service both in
this introductory session,
followed by an advanced one.
For this introductory course
session, it's very basic, like
what is a datastore as well
as some internals.
We'll talk about how the
underlying BigTable provides
the scalability and reliability
issue of the data store.
And finally, we'll go beyond
theory by covering more
practical operations about
how to use the datastore.
There are many definitions of
the datastore but very simply
and easy to understand, it's a
persistent storage for App
Engine data.
Why does App Engine need
to store the data?
You've already learned that App
Engine is the framework to
run the web application.
Its nature is very scalable.
Basically, the scalability means
that if your application
is a surge on the load, it
automatically increases the
number of instances.
So we need some central place
to save the data, otherwise
this instance and that
instance would return
different results for
the same request.
This is not an App Engine
specific problem.
If you've worked on other
traditional web applications
such as CGI to the more recent
PHP, relational databases and
datastores for App Engine is a
counterpart of the relational
database or RDB.
So the question is, why
don't we use an RTB?
Why does Google provide
datastore instead of using
some relational database?
The answer is really easy--
scalability.
So if the App Engine is highly
scalable, this datastore must
also match its scalability.
Let's look into database
scalability to explain why
Google uses datastore as
database for App Engine.
So let's first compare
the datastore
with relational databases.
If I look clearly, an RDB
supports the following
functionality.
It includes a table JOIN,
flexible filtering, and
subqueries.
The datastore supports some of
these, but its functionality
is limited to the simple
filtering and sorting.
On the other hand, datastore
is highly scalable and
reliable without sacrificing
performance.
RDBs, however, are really
difficult to scale.
First, let's look at a server
configuration of databases.
The server can be a
single instance.
This is a simple configuration,
but here the
performance of the system is
limited by hardware resources
of the machine.
And it's going to be the single
point of failure.
If we have replication or
copies, it increases the
reliability.
But here arises the issue of
consistency among all server
instances, We can also shard.
Now, shard means split the
server or data into multiple
machines, so that the multiple
machines altogether work as
one machine.
If we shard the database,
we often must look for
transactions which will become
more complicated.
Let's talk about consistency,
which I'm going to use a lot.
Consistency can have
two levels--
strong or eventual.
Strong consistency means that
the data is always consistent,
whatever happens into whatever
server to query.
When write operation is
finished, data is already
consistent among all servers.
Or if a server fails in the
middle of a write operation or
in the middle of whatever
operation, all servers return
the same result.
Eventual consistency indicates
that data will eventually be
consistent.
But we have a certain timeframe
where data is not
consistent.
DNS or domain name services is
a good and easy to understand
example of eventual
consistency.
DNS is thought of
as a worldwide
distributed database system.
When you update a configuration
on your domain,
it's not reflected to
all DNS immediately.
For a certain period of time,
some DNS servers return old
configurations and others return
the new configuration.
But eventually, all DNS
servers return the new
configuration.
A traditional RDB ensures
strong consistency.
This is the reason why it's
hard to ensure scalability
without sacrificing performance
in RGB and the
reason why Google pursued
another solution, datastore,
for App Engine.
Datastore is based on BigTable,
which is a super
high scalability underlying
technology
used throughout Google.
And BigTable is a key for
datastore to secure
scalability.
So we'll spend some time to look
into BigTable and how it
achieves it.
So this is the BigTable.
It's a mechanism to offer
scalability to the datastore.
So what is a BigTable?
BigTable is a scalable,
distributed, highly available
and structured storage.
So the key thing here
is a BigTable is not
a database by itself.
It doesn't support the query.
So it's storage of the data.
It has strong consistency
for a single row.
And I think the best part is,
it's being used throughout
Google for more than
seven years.
And it's used by web search,
YouTube, analytics, and many
other projects throughout.
This is a pretty picture about
how the BigTable scales and is
really the key of scalability.
Take a close look at one shard
of data in the BigTable
tablet, which is just the
name of the server.
So this shard, this
tablet server,
has many write requests.
It has so many write requests
that it needs to multiply.
And then we have two sets
of tablets servers.
So then the load is distributed
into two servers,
two tablets.
And this happens
automatically.
So you don't really need to care
about whether you need to
increase the number of
servers or tablets.
This is the BigTable
data model.
Big data is data storage, and
it's a key value data storage.
So here in BigTable, we call
a value as columns.
And internally in those,
the data is
sorted by a key order--
key and lexical order.
And the facts are sorted by key
to enable the range query
by the application.
Application means the user
of the BigTable.
Here is one BigTable support.
BigTable supports CRUD.
Now that's create, read, update,
and delete operations
on our own.
And it's strong consistency
but not multiple rows.
And the support scans
by range of keys.
So in this example, we're
retrieving the rows with
prefix B. You want
B to be three.
Or in the second example, you
can get rows with keys ranging
from B to D. So this is
what BigTable can do.
But what BigTable can't do is
search by column values.
So you can't get column or
rows where the column has
certain values.
This is a limitation
of BigTable.
Yes, this is a Google solution
for the datastore.
It's actually how we secure with
scalability, reliability,
and performance.
So the scalability is based on
BigTable automated sharding.
BigTable applications
are reliable.
It ensures access to your data
if the server is down.
And Megastore supports
transactions, which offer you
the strong consistency.
Finally, performance--
reducing the lock granularity
and allows
co-location of the data.
So during the transaction,
the data you need can
be safe in one shard.
So that drastically reduces
the necessity of the
communication be
with the shard.
This is a big difference from
the relational database.
This is how you know Google
achieves these three.
This is the internals
of the datastore.
Let's move on to the
actual usage part--
the practical part.
The datastore and RDB use
different terms for the same
corresponding concepts.
For example, the category of the
object, which type of the
object, is a kind in datastore
versus a table in RDB.
And the one entry of the data is
an entity instead of a row.
And the unique identifier or
a file is a key in both.
The individual data in the
entity is called the property
instead of the field in RDB.
Perhaps this real example will
be easier to understand.
Here's an example
application of a
blog with social features.
We have two kinds
of data here--
a blog entry and a user.
Each key is unique with one
blog entry and two users.
These are called entities.
The property is the actual
data you want to
store in the datastore.
So in this example, the blog
entry, the name, message and
date are the properties.
Note user Joe has
two followers.
And the property has multiple
values here.
It's different from an RDB
structure where we use two
tables, one for user
and another for
relations of users.
Also, Joe has no followers,
which is also valid.
Datastore allows us
to have multiple
data for one property.
And it also allows the
empty data like this.
So this is the other big
difference from RDB.
This is a more practical example
about how we create an
entry or entity in a
Java low-level API.
The point is we first create
an entity Java object.
Then we set properties.
And finally, we put this Java
object into the datastore with
this put function, which
actually communicates with the
datastore and it
saves the data.
This same pattern is
used in Python.
First create a Python object.
Then set properties, either by
giving values to constructor
or by setting values
afterwards.
And lastly, put saves the
data into the datastore.
These are only some examples of
the low-level APIs in both
Java and Python.
We actually have various kinds
of APIs and also some third
party frameworks for Java
you can choose from.
You might want one with a
standard API providing you
with more portability
or one with more
functionality, like caching.
Or another to use more
high level APIs.
We might introduce new APIs.
So some API might
be deprecated.
It can change from
time to time.
The most important thing to
remember from this lesson is
the datastore is a highly
scalable and highly reliable
database that Google offers
for App Engine.
Finally, here are some more
documents you may want to
refer to for more details.